the song sweet melissa that's the first
song i've ever wrote oh is it yeah oh i
didn't read that when i was 17. no
kidding was it about an actual girl
named melissa no i was out on the road
for the first time yeah i guess i was a
little homesick
so i just invented this girl and i wrote
the whole damn song
except for the title
but back home it'll always run
to sweet barbara
you know we need three syllable now yeah
so
i finally just
any time you get hung up on something
it's best just put it down yeah and when
you pick it up again later
who knows right so it was my turn
to go
to the grocery right and get coffee and
sugar and all that stuff
beans and bacon you know
range right
anyway
uh
me and another person were the only ones
because it was like four in the morning
so
this was an old spanish lady i guess
her granddaughter
she couldn't speak much english at all
right the little toddler had just
learned that she had legs that worked
boy she was
running around i'm telling you
and she took off one time
way out of earshot and uh
the lady yells melissa come back melissa
i went oh
there it is
sweet melissa i started to go up and
kiss her on the cheek but she was
probably calling the law
that was it the three-syllable name you
needed
that is crazy how that works if you
hadn't gotten to the store you would
have missed it who knew
you